تحرش جنسي في السفارة
الاسرائيلية بالرباط. اصحاب
غواصاتها الخاصة. وزير الخارجية
الاماراتي عبدالله بن زايد ال
الملكة اليزابيث الثانية المقررة
الاثنين المقبل. جدد اعضاء مجلس
راعية للارهاب بايدن كان قد رفض
هذه الخطوة باعتبارها ستؤجج
الاذربيجانيين. وعلى ارمينيا ان
تتحمل نتائج موقفها العدواني
الى جانب اذربيجان. هنا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان يقول على
طائرات مسيرة تابعة للجيش
الاذربيجاني وهي تقصف مواقع على
الالاف. ارمينيا اعترفت ان
اذربيجان تمكنت من احتلال عشرة
يتصاعد اكثر والضحايا في ازدياد.
انتشرت مقاطع فيديو تظهر قيام
رفيع المستوى تزامنا مع الاحتفال
بمرور عامين على ابرام الاتفاق
الاحتلال يا لهذه الوقاحة!
الدكتورة الونا فيشرك هام سفيرة
قرارات حاسمة سيتم تطبيقها على
ارض الواقع. خطوة جريئة نفذ
البحرية ردا على الاستفزازات
الامريكية بشأن تايوان اندريه
للبلدين. بالمختصر البحرية
الروسية ادخلتها الصين في مياهها
نهيان يصل اسرائيل في زيارة
رسمية رفقة وفد رسمي واقتصادي
الغواصات الامريكية لن تصل قريبا
وفرنسا تعرض البديل فرنسية
تفاجئ العالم بارقام مفاجئة
لطلبات ووجهات الاستيراد صادمة.
الابراهيمي للسلام بين الامارات
واسرائيل. بالتطبيع مع كيان
بداعي ممارستها ضغطا على الشركات
المصنعة للهواتف بنظام
نهائيا في حق شركة جوجل بغرامة
تجاوزت اربعة مليارات دولار
الاندرويد. انها دعوات اصحاب
قنوات يوتيوب المظلومين. روسيا
العيون الضيقة يفتحون لبوتين
المحيطة الهادئ لكبح استفزازات
كيان الاحتلال الجديدة في المغرب
بعد سحب السفير السابق اثر فضيحة
الروسية والصينية في المحيط
الهادئ. تنفذ في هذه اللحظات
تعزيز التعاون البحري بين موسكو
وبكين. والحفاظ على السلام
العالم كله ان يدرك اننا كما كنا
دوما نقف الى جانب اخوتنا
الشيوخ الامريكي دعوتهم لاقرار
مشروع قانون لتصنيف روسيا دولة
السويسريين بالاستحمام الجماعي
وفي خمس دقائق في اوروبا توفيرا
ارمينيا قتلوا خلال الساعات
الاربع والعشرين في الاشتباكات
نعم اوروبا على رأس المستوردين.
وزيرة الطاقة السويسرية توصي
الصراع مع موسكو. اصدرت المحكمة
العليا للاتحاد الاوروبي قرارا
تقليدية فيما اقترح مسؤولون
استراليون ان تقوم كامبيرا ببناء
للطاقة لهذا التقشف المضحك وغير
المقبول. صدمة لاستراليا.
كيلومترات مربعة من اراضيها. وان
ما لا يقل عن مائة وخمسة من قوات
المتواصل. احداث والتطورات.
روسيا وبلا روسيا وميانمار ثلاث
دول رفضت بريطانيا توجيه دعوة
لزعمائها لحضور مراسم جنازة
القتال في اوكرانيا وانها قتلت
نحو ثمانمائة عسكري اوكراني في
الحديث نصر اوكرانيا وكانه يشعر
بوجود شيء غير طبيعي. امريكا لا
ليقترب اكثر من حليفه الاقوى
وصديقه المقرب حسب وصفه. ومن اجل
الحدودية مع اذربيجان. الموقف
التركي الرسمي يتصاعد ويزداد قوة
من ردة فعل الروس. ومع ارتفاع
نشوة النصر القوات الاوكرانية
تعمل حاليا على مناورات وتدريبات
قتالية بالقرب من الحدود
المتنازع عليها بعد عامين من
مواجهة دامية اسفرت عن مقتل
غضبها؟ لهيب الحرب يزداد. صراع
الحدود بين اذربيجان وارمينيا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة لتشتعل
واشنطن غضبا فمن سيطفئ نار
الهادئ منه وذلك بسبب مناورات
تكتيكية مشتركة بين البحرية
والاستقرار في منطقة اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ ومراقبة المنطقة
اونتيكوف. الصين لن تسمح بمزيد
من الضغوطات على روسيا وهناك
لاقامة اية علاقات تجارية او
بيزنس مع موسكو نعم يا سادة.
التوترات اندلعت مرة اخرى بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا بشأن منطقة
الحدود مع ارمينيا في اتجاهات
ولاتشين والزنجيلان وكانت
البحرية اضافة الى حماية اهداف
النشاط الاقتصادي البحري
تزامنا مع دوريات بحرية مشتركة
مع الصين وتشمل مهام الدوريات
الرئيس الصيني روسيا كما اعتبر
ان الوقت الحالي غير مناسب
بالصواريخ بعيدة المدى. وقد يكون
السبب واحدا وهو الخشية من تصادم
الالمان? الصين تزعج ابناء العم
سهام. نزل من طائرته رافعا يده
امل كبيرة صدمت الجيش الاوكراني
بعد ان رفضت المانيا تزويد
ثمانية الاف كيلومتر فقط ليظهر
بايدن هنا ويقول انه من المبكر
تهتز صنارة صيده. فالمساحة التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا تقدر بستمائة
وهذا ما يزيد الشكوك حول مصيدة
عسكرية. وان بوتين فقط ينتظر ان
ان يطمئنه قال له ندعم سياسة
الصين الواحدة وندين الاستفزازات
مخيبة للامال. مكاسبنا في ارض
المعركة لن تتغير او تتأثر.
اوكرانيا بالدبابات والمدرعات.
وذلك عقب رفض واشنطن مد اوكرانيا
روسيا والصين تقاربهما يزعج
الغرب. حتى ان امواج المحيط
الصين وعلى لسان جون كيربي قائلا
ان بلاده تراقب الى اي مدى سيدعم
الامريكية في تايوان. توجه حينها
واشنطن رسالة تحذيرية عاجلة الى
الى ارض ويعتبرها الروس اعتداء
واضحا. فما رأيكم انتم بردة فعل
خاركيب وميكولييف والدونيسك
وزغروتش على حد تعبيرها. خيبة
الاوكرانية خسائر بشرية كبيرة
لليوم الماضي في مختلف محاور
لتظهر هنا وزارة الدفاع الروسية
قائلة انها كبدت القوات
البلاروسية بالتحديد. نعم ها هو
ديلانسكي يضع يده على قلبه ويردد
النشيد الوطني في مدينة ازيوم
ومن امام مبنى البلدية صافرة
الانذار تدوي من جديد في مجمل
اراضي اوكرانيا. ما الذي يحدث
وخمسة وعشرين الف كيلو متر بينما
يحتفل الرئيس الاوكراني باستعادة
بينما يرد الجانب الالماني انه
حرص امني خشية دخول هذه الدبابات
تنسب لنفسها الانتصارات التي تم
تحقيقها في اوكرانيا وذلك حرصا
برلين عدم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات والمدرعات هو اشارة
ومضادة للدبابات بالاضافة الى
غرف عمليات مشتركة تدار بالاقمار
عسكري مباشر مع الدب الروسي.
وزارة الدفاع الاوكراني. قرار
الصناعية لتحديد الاهداف
العسكرية. ليأتي الاعلان هنا من
انخراطها في مواجهة عسكرية
مباشرة مع روسيا وانها ستكون
ومتطورة لاوكرانيا. هذا وقد تحدث
العديد من الخبراء العسكريين انه
الرد. هكذا قالت ماريا زا خروف
ولم يكتف بذلك. بل ارسلوا السفير
وتم تفعيلهم بشكل مباشر مع بداية
الهجوم وما يثير حيرة الخبراء
العسكريين ان بوتين يتجاهل
الخسائر الروسية في حتى الان
من الاسلحة بل تحترم عقولنا
قليلا. لتدخل على الخط الرئاسة
وصواريخ الحديثة وصواريخ ومدافع
وراجمات وصواريخ انظمة رادارات
جزءا لا يتجزأ من الصراع القائم.
فما هي هذه الاسلحة التي ازعجت
البلاروسية لا نعلم ما هو الهدف
من هذه المناورات ولماذا الحدود
روسيا مروحية من طراز وطائرات
مسيرة من طراز ونظام صواريخ
السياسية مشيا على الاقدام. لقد
تجاوزتم الخطوط الحمراء ولنا حق
وزارة الدفاع امريكية ان واشنطن
لا تستبعد خيارات تسليح جديدة
تم ارسال خلايا نائمة لجنود
اوكران منغمسين بين المواطنين.
الروسي لواشنطن ليبلغهم ان
الجانب الروسي يحذر الادارة
بوتين انفجرت تلاها دخان كثيف.
ورغم ذلك تمكنت سيارة الرئيس
مهلا مهلا يا صحيفة ديلي ميل
البريطانية سيارة بوتين مدرعة
المتحدث باسم الرئاسة قال ان
اصابة الرئيس جاءت بعد ساعات
الامريكية بعدم ارسال صواريخ
بعيدة المدى لكييف لان ذلك يعني
دون توقف. واضافت الصحيفة ان
العجلة الامامية اليسرى لسيارة
واطارات السيارات المدرعة لا
تنفجر. ليس هذا فحسب بل ان سيارة
بوتين مصممة ضد اي هجمات حتى على
مستوى قذائف الار بي جي وغيرها
الروسي من الخروج من طريق
الهجوم. ووصلت الى مكان امن.
المرور العالمي للاغتيالات.
لنكمل رحلتنا الى الطاولات
قليلة من زيارته لمدينة ازيوم.
وان اصابته ليست خطيرة. انه يوم
الاوكرانية وتعلن عن تعرض سيارة
الرئيس الاوكراني. لحادث سير.
بريطانيا توجه ثلاث رسائل محرجة
لثلاث دول بشأن جنازة الملكة
تعرضت للهجوم حيث اوضح التقرير
ان الرئيس الروسي كان مسافرا الى
بوتين لمحاولة اغتيال ومن اشهرها
صحيفة ديلي ميل البريطانية حيث
اعترضت سيارة اسعاف اول سيارة
مرافقة فيما استمر بقية الموكب
دولة الاحتلال الاسرائيلي. رسائل
روسية. صحف بريطانية تشير لتعرض
اليزابيث. ولهذا السبب يحتفل
وزير الخارجية الاماراتية في
مقر اقامته الرسمي وفي موعد غير
محدد. واثناء مرور موكبه الرئاسي
افادت في تقرير لها بان سيارة
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
الحربية صوب هذه الدولة
واستراليا تتلقى اشعارا من
واشنطن بشأن الغواصات النووية
لتسخر منها فرنسا. بينما
الاوكرانيين بهذا الاجراء
والرئيس التركي يرسل طائرته
تخضع عدوك دون قتال. سياسة حكيمة
يستخدمها اصحاب العيون الضيقة.
نعم. الصين تدخل روسيا في خط
المواجهة مع تايوان لتضع واشنطن
ان اسرع طريقة لانهاء الحرب هي
ان تخسرها. ومن فنون الحروب ان
سفيرها تجنبا لاي عسكرية مع
امريكا. والمانيا تغضب
واشنطن برأيكم كيف سترد امريكا
هذه الخطوة الماكرة.
في ورطة. بينما بوتين يتعرض
لمحاولة اغتيال لترسل روسيا